باحد اللقاءات اخبرني انه يعني كاتب رساله
ويطلب مني ايصالها الزعيم عربي كان على
علاقه وطيده مع الرئيس يعني اثناء الحكم
وهذا الزعيم العربي يحمل من صفات العروبيه
والشهامه العربيه ما يعني يعجز عن الوصف
المشكله هناك كيف اطلع الرساله يعني كيف
اخذها
فعمليه اخراج الرساله
بطريقه معقده يعني الطريقه لازم تجانب
الامريكي يعني حذر جدا عندما امد ايدي
بجيبي وحذر جدا اذا اسحب اي ورقه استلمها
من رئيس مباشره
فبطريقه ما ما اريد اذكرها حصلت على
الرساله
يعني بالطريق كيف يعني على الاقل
كان كنا نلتقي اني الرئيس بقياده
قوات الماريز هذا مقر لقاده الجيش
الامريكي ومقر ايضا للسجن كبار قاده
النظام الوطني
عمليا عدد القاعه اللي احنا فيها البقيه
الاماكن ما مراقبه فيروح الرئيس يعني يعني
يطلب
الذهاب الى الحمام اثناء السير يعني
بالممر يقدر يمد ايده على يعني جيبته
ويلتقط الرساله ويغطيها بمحارم فمن يغطيهم
محارم يبقى يستعملها يمسح بها وجهها
ويخليها على الطاوله اللي احنا قريبين
اقوم انا يعني تقطيع يعني عدد من
[موسيقى]
هاي المحارم ووضعها بيني وبين الرئيس حتى
اغطي على الاولى فمن اسحبها خليها فوق
الاجنده لانه ما اقدر لا اخليها بالاجنده
او بين اوراقي ولا اخليها لان يراقبونا
الامريكان من مكانيا متقابلين من نوافذ
زجاجيه ضباط يراقبونا
ناهيك عن الرقابه الالكترونيه اللي اكيد
احنا محتسبينها
بهاي الطريقه احمل الرسائل القاده العرب
شو كان في حواها فحواها بالبدايه يعني
سلام وعتب على هذا القائد انه يفترض يعني
من حق الكبير على اهله هم اللي يسالون
عليه لكن انا اتجاوز الظروف المحيطه به كل
المحيطه بالعالم العربي واني اسلم عليك
يعني بادرت من عندي انه تستخدمون علاقتكم
مع الجانب الامريكي لحقت دماء الشعب
العراقي ولحقن دماء اصدقائكم الامريكان
وراح تكون المبادره مقبوله منك كون يعني
ثقلك العربي وثق لك بالعلاقات الامريكيه
احنا ننتصر بالاخير وانا ما اطلب منك
النجده لنجده رقم صدام حسين وانما اطلب من
عندك حقن الدماء
او وصلت الرساله
وقابلت ذلك القائد العربي ورحب بي ترحيب
واستقبال طيب
وحملني رساله الى الرئيس صدام حسين الله
يرحمه وسالني على الرساله ان كان يعني لدى
الجامعه الامريكي علم بها اكدت لانه
الجامعه الامريكي ما يعلم بها
ثم ماذا حصل هل صار في تصرف هالاتجاه صار
تصرف يعني مع الامريكان لكن
يعني لعوامل عديده ما ثماره بس صدام حسين
ورفض عرض او احد العروض اللاحقه بموضوع
النفي الى بلد اخر
رساله متعلق اطلاق الصراحه رساله تعلق
بمبادره لحقن دماء الامريكيين
الجنود الامريكان
والمقاتلين العراقي بمصيره هو شخصيا لا لا